no más petróleo importado de Rusia para
fin de año Ese fue el plan que dio a
conocer la ministra de relaciones
exteriores de Alemania como parte de las
sanciones contra el kremlin por la
invasión a Ucrania viajamos
cometimos errores en el pasado
Precisamente en esta área pero no
podemos recuperar el pasado ahora
tenemos que poner fin a nuestras
importaciones de energía rusa aún más
ahora
por lo tanto digo Aquí Clara e
inequívocamente que sí
Alemania está eliminando completamente
las importaciones de energía de Rusia
reduciremos el petróleo a la mitad para
el verano y estaremos en cero para fin
de año
[Música]
las declaraciones fueron formuladas en
riga capital de letonia en el contexto
de una reunión con sus homólogos de
lituania Estonia y el canciller
anfitrión en el encuentro se dejó Clara
la posición de los 27 miembros de la
Unión Europea en cuanto a cortar las
dependencias energéticas
Pero al final del día Déjenme
recordarles que no solo Alemania o los
estados bálticos deciden sobre las
sanciones son los 27 estados miembros es
una decisión unánime es nuestra decisión
común La ministra alemana no dejó claro
que el mercado de combustible se
reemplazará al ruso sin embargo dejó
saber el plan del bloque continental
la eliminación de los combustibles
fósiles es un doble factor de seguridad
aparte de La amenaza rusa está claro que
solo podemos crear una seguridad y una
paz sostenible en todo el mundo si
también tomamos medidas conjuntas
decididas contra la crisis climática
esto incluye llegar a la neutralidad del
co2 en Europa lo antes posible
al comienzo de la invasión a Ucrania
Rusia aportaba el 55% del gas que
consumía Alemania lo que la convierte en
una de las naciones más cautelosas a la
hora de aplicar sanciones a los
combustibles rusos el anuncio llegó
junto con la confirmación de que Berlín
no dispone de equipamiento militar de
reserva para enviar a Ucrania y que
ofrecerá a cambio apoyo logístico de
mantenimiento y formación